now stain its home for almost five weeks
has changed the way in which we are
living our lives and I know how tough
this has been huge sacrifices have been
made jobs have been lost to people's
futures have been put on hold weddings
have been cancelled families have been
able to see one another every single
person across our United Kingdom has
given up a great deal from the
vulnerable the elderly those
self-isolation
alone to the hundreds and thousands of
small and medium-sized businesses to the
children and young people whose
education has been put on hold this
extraordinary national effort has been
quite remarkable and I'm grateful to
everybody for playing their part but we
should not lose sight of the fact that
this country's efforts are working so my
thanks goes to the British people you
have fostered a spirit of national unity
that is helping us to get through this
challenge in time the action we are
collectively taking is working and your
sacrifices are undoubtedly saving lives
we know that people are frustrated but
we are not out of danger yet it is
imperative that people continue to
follow the rules designed to protect
their families their friends and their
loved ones this will continue to save
lives we all want to return to live in
our lives as normally as possible and of
course as soon and as safely as we can
and that is what the entire government
is working towards